et pour parler nous sommes en direct
avec vincent chaudel fondateur de
l'observatoire du sport business
monsieur cheval bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur les retraites
rt france alors des annulations ou qui
ont un coût conséquent sur l'économie
comment le monde du sport va pouvoir
surmonter cette épreuve
comment il va pouvoir supporter ça
dépend toujours de la durée de l'épreuve
c'est la vraie question aujourd'hui
c'est de savoir si on est sur un report
ou sur des annulations
si l'épisode de coronavirus permet aux
championnats de reprendre et de se
terminer à fin juin
alors il y aura juste entre guillemets
un problème de trésorerie c'est à dire
comment je finance l'activité de mon
club pendant un mois ou deux à parer le
problème c'est si les championnats ne
vont pas jusqu'à leur terme et que l'on
repart sur une nouvelle saison à ce
moment-là il y as forcément un problème
si je prends le cas de la france
le championnat s'est disputée pour
l'instant aux trois quarts ça veut dire
que les droits télé ne vont être
pourrait être amputée des 1/4 y compris
pour les droits sponsoring y compris
pour la billetterie est donc là on
aurait tout un écosystème qui seraient
en difficulté des décisions nécessaires
on l'a vu en tout cas pour l'uefa on
sait aussi que roland garros ça va être
reportée comme je le disais au mois de
septembre octobre
ça veut dire qu'il ya vraiment des
risques importants et pour l'instant le
cio n'a pas encore donné de réponse
concernant les jeux olympiques de tokyo
on a l'impression qu'ils font un petit
peu de la résistance puisque le comité
olympique a estimé hier qu'il n'est pas
nécessaire de prendre des décisions
radicales
est ce que c'est une question de
l'inconscience actuellement nonce comme
qu'elles sont bien conscients c'est une
question de manque de visibilité au
moment où on se parle on ne sait pas
combien de temps va durer cette épidémie
et et si on peut reprendre les activités
normales
j'évoquais tout à l'heure le sujet de
calendrier pour le football
si on doit pouvoir reprendre début mai
par exemple ça suppose aussi que les
équipes l'on reprenne l'entraînement et
et puissent disposer d'un certain temps
avant de retrouver la compétition
le problème de des jeux olympiques par
rapport à l'euro l'euro 2020 à une
chance extraordinaire c'est que ce n'est
pas un seul pays qui l'accueillent
il n'y a pas eu beaucoup
d'investissement pour cela puisque
l'euro 2020 va se disputer dans destin
déjà existants le problème des jeux
olympiques de tokyo c'est que le japon a
investi 11 milliards plus de 11
milliards dans l'organisation de cette
compétition dont il ya un enjeu
économique très important et que des
jeux olympiques c'est une trentaine de
fédérations avec enfin une trentaine de
sport pardon avec 200 pays participant
est donc vous multipliez cela par le
nombre de calendrier de compétition
c'est un vrai casse tête chinois déjà
l'uefa a reporté son euro pour pouvoir
alléger les calendriers de chaque pays
l'un si vous le x 30 vous rendrez compte
de la complexité de la chose alors vous
parlais justement de ce calendrier des
compétitions concernant les jeux
olympiques est de toutes ces sélections
de tous ces pays qui doivent y
participer
mais là aussi et tokyo va accueillir
beaucoup plus de monde que l'euro de
football qui sera justement joué dans
différents dans différentes villes
d'europe
oui c'est la complexité en fait c'est le
revers de la médaille pour le sport qui
est qui paye son succès planétaire c'est
à dire qu'effectivement sur les jeux
olympiques le monde entier vient visiter
le pays hôte
c'est un enjeu majeur pour les
organisateurs c'est à dire de pouvoir
accueillir du public et donc là il ya un
vrai problème mais au moment où on se
parle on ne sont ne sait pas dire si au
mois de mai par exemple les sportifs de
tous les pays vont pouvoir reprendre
l'entraînement
si dans toutes les disciplines on aura
pu
aller au bout des qualifications donc on
est vraiment face à des des incertitudes
on est obligé d'imaginer plusieurs
scénarios
le meilleur scénario seront reprendre
qu'à du football c'était de reporter
l'euro ce qui permet effectivement ce
qui devrait permettre à chaque
championnat national d'aller à son terme
et donc de redonner des qualifiés pour
les autres compétitions européennes à
venir
dans le cas des jeux olympiques c'est
encore plus compliqué est reportée à
2021 par exemple semble beaucoup plus
compliqué que pour l'euro de football
donc c'est un problème on peut vivre du
sport à huit clos c'est frustrant bien
évidemment mais si on garde à l'esprit
que la première source de revenus du
sport c'est les droits télé le vrai
sujet c'est déjà de savoir si on peut
remettre en activité
les sportifs et proposer un spectacle
sportif à la télé les spectateurs c'est
très important parce que ça fait partie
de l'événement de la passion mais on
aujourd'hui le vrai sujet c'est de
savoir si bel et bien on va pouvoir
avoir des sportifs sur les terrains est
aujourd'hui les sportifs qu'ils sont
comme vous et moi c'est à dire confiné
et donc du coup ça suppose au moment où
on va arrêter le confinement qui est un
temps de préparation pour qu'on puisse
les retrouver devant nos écrans très
bien en tout cas merci beaucoup
vincent chaudel avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
fondateur de l'observatoire du sport
business